Is anyone else sick to death of politics?
While every politician out there claims that
they work for their constituents, it’s become
increasingly clear over the years that all
they really care about is enriching themselves
and making even more money for the giant,
shady corporations who fund their campaigns.
And with people, understandably, becoming
increasingly disenchanted with the endless
bickering and division of the two-party system,
people wish they had an alternative.
Rather than a politician who claims to be
a good person but is actually secretly evil,
what if, instead, we elected an entity that
we all knew was evil from the beginning?
That’s why today, we’re hitting the anomalous
campaign trail.
Seeing what an utter disaster the world seems
to have been lately, a number of the SCP Foundation’s
most bizarre anomalies have decided that they
could do as good a job as anyone else running
for office right now.
So, let’s hear them out, see what their
campaign promises are, and what fringe new
parties they’re representing.
And of course, we’re a Democracy here at
SCP Explained, as long as we like the results.
So we want to hear from you, the viewers,
on which anomaly has secured your vote and
why!
And with that, let’s put on our political
correspondent hat and get knee-deep into the
dirty, horrific world of these potential Super
Creepy Presidents - Or SCPs.
First of all, we have the most experienced
political operative at the SCP Foundation:
Dr. Jack Bright, representing the “C’mon,
You’ve Had Worse!”
party.
Unlike all of the other anomalies on this
list, if you elect Dr. Bright, this will technically
be his second term in office, given that he
controlled the body of former President George
W. Bush throughout his eight-year presidential
term.
So if you’re willing to overlook the whole
Iraq War thing, he’s got that killer experience.
And hey, for the kind of person who wants
an Everyman President, then Dr. Bright is
the ideal candidate for you - Seeing as he’s
literally occupied the body of every type
of man, woman, child, and some animals.
No matter who you are, Dr. Bright can relate
to your plight.
But maybe, despite his experience, Dr. Bright
still seems like too much of a young buck
to be the leader of the free world.
You want someone sagely and experienced - and
you don’t want to break the streak of having
all world leaders be tapioca-munching senior
citizens.
May we introduce to you SCP-106 of The Pocket
Dimension Party.
He’s an older gentleman, sure, but it’s
given him wisdom that youth could never replicate
- at least in terms of knowing how to torture
people with terrifying efficacy.
He’s also a veteran, having fought and sustained
injuries in the trenches of World War One,
so he’s got the interest of the nation’s
disaffected veterans in mind.
He’s also committed to transparency and
breaking down boundaries - or at least, walking
directly through them.
The biggest downsides of having SCP-106 as
president is the fact he’s a little forgetful
in his old age, and also, every month, he
demands 14 live sacrifices from the US citizenry,
because the job is stressful, he needs to
blow off steam, and he just can’t stand
playing golf.
But hey, maybe, like a lot of people out there,
your biggest concern on the ballot is healthcare.
You want to know that your pre-existing conditions
will be covered and that if you end up getting
sick, your treatment will be both effective
and affordable.
You also want to guarantee quick responses
to emerging viral threats, like, say, a Pestilence.
That’s why you might want to cast your vote
for SCP-049, the Plague Doctor, from the End
the Pestilence Party.
Sure, this charming French gentleman may not
have been born in the US, but some rules are
worth bending for the sake of the greater
good.
The Plague Doctor wants to ensure that the
nation and the world are healthy and happy,
no matter how many people he needs to kill
and turn into zombies to do it.
He’s also polite, intelligent, and dignified,
for those who want to add a nice little touch
of European class to the Oval Office.
But perhaps you’re not in it for superficial
qualities.
Maybe you want a president whose every action
comes from a deep well of empathy, and a desire
to make other people happy.
If this sounds like it reflects your personal
opinions and beliefs, then it’s time to
cast your vote for SCP-999, the Tickle Monster,
from the Cuddles for Everyone Party.
999 runs on a strict anti-war platform, instead
hoping to spread love and care among the nation’s
citizens and make the desire to uplift others
part of everyone’s sense of civic duty.
SCP-999 also has big plans for investing in
mental health services, owing to his own long
history working in the field, with a particular
view towards treating people suffering from
depression and PTSD.
Then again, maybe all this talk of love and
flower power has you rolling your eyes.
Maybe you’re someone who fundamentally has
contempt for the human race and wants to vote
for any candidate who’s eager to speed run
us to complete and utter destruction - cause
hey, we had our chance, and we fumbled the
ball.
If you agree with this:
A.
You’re pretty scary.
Please stay away from us.
And B. You’re gonna love SCP-682, the Hard
to Destroy Reptile, the front runner of the
Complete Omnicide Party.
His campaign promises include reinstating
the national death penalty and making breathing
a capital offense, poisoning the water supply,
and launching all the nukes at once, turning
the surface of the earth into lifeless blown
glass.
Hey, at least he’s honest.
We can give him that much.
Maybe you don’t want to destroy the human
race out of sheer, unending hatred, but you
are sick of what a circus politics has become.
It’s a reality show these days - Politicians
aren’t here to fight for your rights and
privileges, they’re here to fight for airtime.
But this isn’t the case with our next presidential
hopeful: SCP-096, the Shy Guy, from the “Oh
god, please, don’t look at me, you doomed
fools!”
party.
He’s not a camera hog - in fact, he’ll
literally annihilate anyone who looks at him.
You’ll find him thoughtfully pacing back
and forth in the Oval Office, muttering to
himself, like Abraham Lincoln, or Nixon.
His aides will get most of the work done,
cause he’ll be too busy sobbing.
Relatable, right?
Haha, we have fun here.
So this next candidate isn’t actually an
anomaly, but he did threaten to break my legs
if I didn’t let him join in, so please,
we present to you, presidential hopeful Dr.
Alto Clef, of the Shoot First, Ask Questions
Later Party.
Being an ex-member of the Global Occult Coalition,
Clef has experience with bureaucracy and being
a government insider, even though his method
of interacting with these systems is typically
extreme, gung-ho violence.
One of Dr. Clef’s major platforms is Gun
Control - as in, when he’s in control, everyone
is going to have so many guns.
So if you yearn for the days of the wild,
wild West, then you ought to give Alto Clef
your vote.
Please don’t, though.
We’re afraid of what he’ll do with more
power.
Okay, so, if none of the rest of these candidates
have impressed you so far, how about a trailblazer?
A president that represents progress?
Not only the first female president, but the
first Hindu president.
And believe it or not, she’s actually testing
extremely well with men.
It’s SCP-029, the Daughter of Shadows, of
the Kneel Before Me Party.
She’s got a long history in leadership with
her generations of Thugee cultists, all of
whom are slavishly devoted to her.
They make KPOP stans look positively fairweather
in comparison.
All her main policies involve worshipping
her, and be sure to avoid her most devoted
followers at the polls if you plan on not
voting for her - they might fly into a blind
rage and strangle you.
Well, that all got a little scary and violent,
didn’t it?
Let’s move away from that, and instead,
think about the nation’s youth for a moment.
Children are the future, and nobody understands
children and their needs better than Dr. Wondertainment,
head of the Lovely Toys for Girls and Boys
Party.
Dr. Wondertainment is a figure of joy and
whimsy, and under President Wondertainment,
the country would become more amusingly whacky
than ever, thanks to every child being guaranteed
some of his marvelous anomalous toys.
But he’s not all fun and games - Dr. Wondertainment
is also a businessman with a long track record
of success, despite being regularly attacked
by the SCP Foundation - so you know under
his presidency, the needs of small businesses
would be understood and taken care of.
But to become president, you need votes, and
to win votes, you need hearts and minds.
Sometimes, the best way to do this is to cultivate
a core voting block of completely devoted,
high-energy voters, like, say...
Furries.
That’s why we think SCP-1471, MalO, of the
Cursed Internet History Party, has what it
takes to battle their way to the top.
We really don’t know much about what MalO
wants to do, specifically, save for loosening
cybersecurity standards so everyone can download
its cursed app.
But really, does a potential president really
need policies and ideals?
Is it not enough that they just make you feel
good?
Sometimes, it’s all just about vibes, and
I think that’s the bravest political stance
to take of all.
Vote MalO, for a DeviantArt future.
Okay, okay, I think we went a little too far
there.
But it’s part of a wider cultural trend.
It seems today that all you see is violence
in movies and sex on TV.
But where are those good, old-fashioned values
on which we used to rely?
Lucky there’s SCP-1867, Lord Blackwood,
for the British Imperial Party, to help set
us all back on track.
He’s an old-fashioned guy from a bygone
era, where women were women, and men were
telepathic sea slugs.
Think of him as a modern-day Teddy Roosevelt:
A renaissance man, skilled in warfare, business,
adventuring, and hunting.
He’s sure to win over voters with his trademark
folksy charm.
And his ability to spin captivating yarns
is likely to help him crush it at debates
and town hall meetings.
But that’s nothing compared to the kinds
of votes you can get when you’re able to
literally control people’s minds with terrifying
psychic abilities.
This is the primary advantage of SCP-035,
the Possessive Mask, representing the Mind-Melting
Arcane Secrets Party.
SCP-035 has access to knowledge so terrifying
that even hearing it would cause you to be
plunged into a state of utterly irrevocable
madness.
And he’s also a very persuasive speaker.
If you attend one of his speeches, you’ll
hear his words slithering into your mind,
slowly rearranging your thoughts like chess
pieces on a board until you’re hanging off
of his every word.
The one downside of his regime would be that
he’d need a revolving door of Vice Presidents
whose bodies he would steal and melt one by
one.
Sometimes, to get what you want, you need
to make compromises, folks.
Okay, before we get too deep into this anomalous
rabbit hole, let’s lean back out for a second
and consider another SCP Foundation insider.
Someone calm, someone measured, someone as
boring as muesli floating in a bowl full of
off-white paint, but reliable as a tough old
mule.
We are, of course, talking of Dr. Charles
Ogden Gears, of the “Doesn’t Like Attending
Parties” Party.
Look, we know he doesn’t play great for
the camera, but sometimes, all you need is
someone who’s got the personality of a piece
of drywall with a complex math equation written
on it, who’ll simply forge on and get the
job done.
That’s what you can expect from Dr. Gears:
He’ll simply get the job done, no bells
and whistles.
Our next candidate, on the other hand, loves
bells - slay bells, specifically.
And that’s slay spelled S.L.A.Y.
That’s right, it’s SCP-4666, the Yule
Man, of the Christmas Party.
He also wants to bring back traditional values
- Specifically, the values of pure, mortal
terror, traditionally experienced by our ancient
ancestors while fleeing from primordial predators.
He will ensure that Christmas is celebrated,
even if his methods of Christmas celebration
are a little...
Well, let’s say “Severe.”
He’ll also introduce a number of policies
to fight climate change, making sure it’s
always nice and cold during the winter.
After all, where’s the fun in standing outside
someone’s bedroom window on Christmas Eve
if there isn’t nice, crunchy snow underfoot?
Maybe you don’t care about Christmas, though.
Maybe you just want a potential president
that’s young and hungry.
And I mean really, really hungry.
We’re talking about SCP-082, Fernand the
Cannibal, of the Donner Party.
And honestly, he might be the most qualified
presidential candidate of anyone on this list.
According to a written note that he sent us,
he’s actually been the president four times
already.
He also got six different PhDs in various
subjects from Harvard, Stanford, and Cornell
University, in addition to two Nobel Prizes,
a Pulitzer-prize-winning series of novels,
and an Oscar-winning screenplay based on his
life as the first man on the moon.
He also apparently has a plan on how to simultaneously
end overpopulation and hunger, but he’s
been a little cagey about the specifics.
But let’s be real here, two of the most
important qualities of a presidential candidate
are clarity and transparency, and that’s
exactly what SCP-055, the Anti-Meme, of the
Non-Spherical Party, promises to offer.
It’s uh...
Um...
You know...
Damn it, it’s on the tip of my tongue...
Okay, it’s gone.
What were we talking about again?
Oh yeah, anomalous presidents, let’s move
on to the next one and see what he’s all
about.
This next candidate has a claim to the childhoods
of millions.
He’s one of the world’s most successful
and acclaimed businessmen and is probably
one of the most famous Americans worldwide.
It’s the cryogenically frozen head of Walt
Disney, also known as SCP-2805, Disney On
Ice, of the Corporate Consolidation Party.
But it’s not just name recognition that
this beloved, beheaded businessman boasts;
it’s also lots and lots of money, which
is valuable for someone campaigning for the
presidency.
And considering the fact that Disney seems
to be rapidly acquiring and owning everything,
I guess it makes sense in the long term that
he’d also end up owning America, too.
But maybe you want a president with a better
head on their shoulders - or at least, a president
whose head is actually attached to their shoulders.
You also want a president who is just a solid
guy.
Solid as a rock.
Or perhaps concrete, and rebar, and Krylon-brand
spray paint...
We’re talking, of course, of SCP-173, of
the Weeping Angel Party.
With some politicians, you get the sense that
they’re only going to do your job when the
public is watching them like a hawk.
The second we look away, they slump back in
their chairs and grab the paddle ball.
SCP-173 is literally the opposite.
He does all his best work while nobody else
is watching.
He’s no talk, all action, and you have to
appreciate that kind of dedication in this
day and age.
When this serious Sculpture is president,
politics is a real snap!
Perhaps you’re of the opinion that the US
needs to take on a more hawkish approach to
international affairs.
You miss the days of constant global wars
and fighting.
You’re the kind of person who listens to
Senator Armstrong ranting in Metal Gear Rising:
Revengeance and thinks, “Hey, this guy actually
has some pretty good ideas.”
Then you’re going to love the idea of our
next prospective president: SCP-076-2, Able,
from the Might Makes Right Party.
Able is really just about one thing, and one
thing only: Fighting.
When he does inevitably lead the country into
a cataclysmic war, he’ll be the first president
since Washington to charge in at the very
front of the army, a pair of ebony swords
drawn and ready to taste blood.
And if he dies on the job, all we need to
do is wait for him to rise from his black
sarcophagus for his term to resume.
How wonderful.
But hey, maybe after all this, you’re completely
disenchanted with the US political system.
You’re tired of presidents, of congress,
of democracy, of the whole complicated mess.
You want to return to a simpler age - an age
of unliteral decisions made by a single, all-powerful
ruler.
Pure monarchism, is what we’re saying.
And who’s a more eager monarch than The
Scarlet King?
This interdimensional nightmare has killed
more Gods than there are grains of sand on
your nearest beach, so there’s probably
no problem on earth he can’t solve if he
puts his diabolical mind to it.
A major downside of being under the Scarlet
King’s Rule is that it would be a lifetime
appointment for him, and the Scarlet King
has an infinite lifespan.
Notions like “freedom”, “hope”, and
“joy“, will have to go out the window,
and instead be replaced with the classic concepts
of terror, rage, and horrendous primal violence.
With the Scarlet King in charge, he’s likely
to also reinstall the long-lost Daevite culture,
some of his most ardent worshippers, so expect
to learn a whole lot about different and interesting
civilizations if the Scarlet King is able
to get his iron clutches on our reality.
What?
Nobody ever said playing politics was nice,
folks.
And there you have it: Our anomalous presidential
nominees, straight from the SCP Foundation.
Which one of these would you vote for?
Are there any nominations we missed?
Let us know down in the comments.
And remember: Whoever wins, we lose.
Well... except 999, that’d be a pretty sweet
deal.
Now go check out “DR.
BRIGHT FOR PRESIDENT SCP-4444 - Bush v. Gore”
and “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King” for more
on your future leaders!